you are not you you're me
very fashion conscious but people have
this idea that it's that it's still the
the promised land you know somewhere
like california which
everything is fruitful and and abundant
but
arnold schwarzenegger is
is the governor of california
there's a perfectly ordinary english
sentence
how did that happen do you know how that
happened
because i'll tell you you know how he
got into that position
he got there by lifting things
now you and me we avoid lifting things
it's unpleasant especially heavy things
even a five-year-old child knows this
they go huh
no [ __ ] no i'm going to put lego up
my arse i'm not doing that no
he took a different approach he lifted
the heavy and you know you lift
something when you have to
piano falls on granny you lift the piano
because granny has mixed feelings about
the whole situation
sunday lunch continues
he didn't do any of that he went right
over to the heavy thing and lifted it
and put it back down and didn't move it
anywhere
and then he lifted it again hundreds of
times
and said to the people who had stopped
to observe this aberrant behavior
look how good i am at lifting the heavy
thing
in my underpants now that
sounds a little dim
but it was they who said you're the man
you're the one we want to deal with
immigration and water rates and taxes
and all that kind of [ __ ]
no wait
what we need to know is how bad was his
predecessor
at that job you know this must have been
somebody who came to work covered in
children's blood every morning
i don't know man it's crazy too much you
know i respect the art
like i get upset when i hear about these
actors to get paid 20 million dollars a
movie
to act and the key word is act but they
paid us the dudes who never could
[ __ ] act how do you pay stallone in
schwarzenegger
20 million dollars a movie pay that to
the dudes who deserve it like pacino
dinero denzel
morgan this has a [ __ ] actress man
because to this day one of my favorite
movies of all time
his heat with pacino and dinero anybody
that's ever seen the movie knows what
i'm talking about
it's like they took the two greatest
actors of all time and put them in a
scene together if you've never seen the
movie go rent it smoke a joint it's
great they got that scene where they
meet for the first time and pacino's
sitting there with de niro he's bringing
[ __ ] down to him he's like
you sir i'm a bad guy i
am the police it's my job to stop guys
like you
murderers rapers killers that's what i
do
there may come a time when i pass cross
i'm gonna have to take you down i won't
like it but i'll do it keeps me hot
on my toes where i gotta be
de niro comes back you know there's a
flip side to that coin
good friend of mine jimmy once told me
never get attached to anything that you
cannot walk out on in 15 seconds flat if
you spot the heat
coming around the corner and i also like
guys like you like guys like me because
you keep me hot
on my toes but i gotta beg
and you're right i pads they may cross
i'm gonna have to take you down
i won't like it but i will not hesitate
great scene now hold up picture the same
scene with stallone and schwarzenegger
you ain't gonna be able to understand
[ __ ] stallone is doing but
you know there's a flip side to decline
i must have to take it down
i won't like it without doing it wow
even deaf people like what do you think
what do you think
can you imagine him asking his woman for
head maria come on give me heckle down
don't come up for air please do your
ears
fellas you want to freak your woman out
during sex make that noise what the [ __ ]
up
you'll be hitting him from the back
the [ __ ] is wrong with you don't worry
about his grinding up here
put your head down ladies are to work
for you too you don't want to get your
man head do that it'll stop immediately
as soon as you get down there how [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
what you making keys or something
no you ain't gonna put a handicap sign
on my balls i'm good to go that's a good
noise to make if you want privacy in a
public bathroom you would clear that
[ __ ] right out
as soon as you get in there
sir you all right get out get away
there's going to be an explosion
gentle the chopper i don't know why he
says that he says that in every move
can't do the chopper now
i like to make that noise on a crowded
elevator especially if i got the fart
people just assumed there's something
wrong with me as soon as i rip one oh my
god what was that
smell it's nice to smell it
get through the chocolate get down oh my
god he's [ __ ]
he didn't even have a helmet on
actually i actually met arnold
schwarzenegger man
true story i was doing a show in san
jose california
and it's like a five and a half hour
drive outside of l.a and i stopped at a
chevron
and this [ __ ] was on pump number
seven filling up his h2
now i don't really get star struck like
if this had been van damme or cigar i'd
have been like
whatever this is [ __ ] terminator this
is conan like i grew up on this
[ __ ]
and i saw him and i was so excited i was
like yo arnold man i love your [ __ ]
he ain't even look at me he was just
like yeah how are you
and i called my boy and i said [ __ ] you
ain't gonna believe it arnold
schwarzenegger he's on pump number seven
filling up he was like [ __ ] you lying i
said i swear to god he was like arnold
schwarzenegger i said [ __ ]
and arnold heard me and i swear he went
just like this
it's like his marco polo he understood
it was like a mating call he knew
some of the fellas might remember where
i got that remember the scene in
predator when he got ready to fight the
alien and covered himself with mud he
was like i'm here
killing me come on do it
that's [ __ ] funny man
all my heroes are going down
arnold schwarzenegger another great man
another great man taken down by that
gold-digging [ __ ] of a man he's got
and i'm not i'm not saying he's not a
piece of [ __ ] for doing what he did was
a piece of [ __ ] move
but how come only he got chastised what
about the maid
why was she called the maid that entire
story she was never called a [ __ ] ever
just boggled my mind she knew his wife
first name basis played with their kids
[ __ ] her husband in their own goddamn
bed that's right down the checklist
first ballot hall of fame [ __ ] right
there
never why do you think she hooked up
with them
because of that 1987 flat top he's still
rocking
the giant space between his teeth i
could put this mic cord through
or i think maybe it's all that
kindergarten cop money laying around the
goddamn bedroom
no it's awful it's a horrific thing to
see as a guy watching guys go through
that [ __ ]
you know and then there's no there's no
sort of examination of it they just go
he's an idiot hey stupid that guy's
stupid if that guy's stupid what the
[ __ ] am i
right
does it even make sense why would you do
that why would you accomplish all that
and then [ __ ] it up
hooking up with one of the ugliest human
beings i've ever seen in my life
not saying i'm a prize i'm just saying
you know
there's got to be something beyond that
right
you know i think it is i think it comes
down to the way he talks you know
[Music]
that dude should be unloading trucks in
transylvania
that should be that should have been the
height of his success
but because he's a great man he had the
balls to move to america
became famous for lifting weights i lift
weights
nobody gives a [ __ ] lifts weights
becomes super famous did he rest on his
laurels no
next challenge i'm going to become an
actor despite the fact that nobody can
really understand me
against all odds he starts making movies
get down
there's a bomb gets out of there
becomes one of the biggest blockbuster
stars of all time
what are you gonna do next arnie i think
amanda kennedy there's no [ __ ] way
you can do that
bam he does it cherry on top i'm running
for governor of a state i can't even
pronounce
and he wins the election
why wouldn't this guy think he couldn't
bang his maid in his own bed
and get away with it this dude has been
in the zone for over four decades
four decades nothing but net
bang a maid in my own bed dude that's a
layup
are you serious i had a hit movie with
the [ __ ]
i don't even need a condom
right and then what happens the smoke
clears
then all these trolls come out of the
woodwork and start judging this great
man
all these fatties these [ __ ] old guys
who never got any with their jowls
coming on tv absolutely reprehensible
behavior
what kind of a public servant his
legacy is starting
like they have any idea what it's like
to be tempted at that level
right like they have groupies as they
waddle out to their mercury tracer
parked on the other side of a dumpster
really you're beating them off
[Applause]
this guy he's not a great man anymore
terminator doesn't count is that what
the [ __ ] you're telling me
because he [ __ ] alice really he's
still not a great man because he did
that then that's the whole thing's over
anybody here think they could move to
austria learn the language become famous
for working out
then be a movie star then marry into
their royalty and hold public office how
many
lifetimes would you need i'm on my third
attempt at rosetta stone spanish
right how can i judge these guys
i can barely handle the temptations of
facebook
i'm gonna judge tiger woods i golf i
don't walk off the 18th hole there's a
busload of scandinavian women waiting to
[ __ ] my brains out
sorry ladies gotta go home to the wife
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
the other story we were talking about as
ecstasy of gold was playing was
good old arnold schwarzenegger executed
the oldest inmate there in california
what was the guy death dumb and blind or
something
god took care god gave him a death
sentence [ __ ] guys on death row
playing uh pinball and
[ __ ] arnie comes in and kills uh
governor governor uh could you let him
off the hook or anything
no kill him i
he he was like uh some bad ass
[ __ ] though back in the day
right
there he is he's overwatching him up on
television i had to kill him
he was of an inferior race
my father was a nazi we got to get some
clips of arnold schwarzenegger if the
guys are listening in the back
well everyone thought i guess because
you know he's a hollywood guy when he
was presented uh with the first case
where
he was able to uh he had the opportunity
to grant clemency uh to somebody on
death row and he didn't do it
and now he's just ah cook him i could
care less at least he's equal
opportunity you know [ __ ] tooky and
i'm [ __ ] saying oh cracker who just
that's right he's got two in a
wheelchair yeah you were ready
really and they both begged them for
forgiveness
he was like the last [ __ ] guy there's
the last
chance these guys had was arnold
schwarzenegger you know you know tooky
probably enjoyed his movies and [ __ ] i
love [ __ ] predator oh he's like
the worst one it's like ah give me three
lines from total recall you can live
all right
predator who played the guy
with the big helicopter machine gun
answer that
[Laughter]
one of my catchphrases from running man
give to me
what did i tell the guy from the
warriors
in that other movie what did i tell him
on the rooftop when
until two years after that [ __ ] damn
you know i saw it on terminator 2 [ __ ]
i know the mud you put the mud on
yourself
uh and the predator couldn't see you and
[ __ ] but
kill him kill him oh my god